welcome to another episode of not too
deep with me your host grace Helbig this
I cannot believe has not already
happened but finally we have Barbara
Dunkleman as you will learn colloquially
called Barbara dongle Minh on this
episode of not too deep
she's been someone that I've known in
the digital space for years and years
and years we have so many similarities
it's insane she's one of the strongest
creative forces being the roosterteeth
if you don't know get ready because she
wears a thousand hats press them really
really well I wish I could spend 10
hours talking to this human because we
have very similar creative paths and I
am so odd and inspired by the way that
she's been able to build a very
energetic curious sexually explorative
path in the nerd geek community
you'll learn way more and also her
parents have been on board the whole
trip can you believe it and during this
episode of not too deep finally with
Barbara Dunkleman turn your great idea
into a reality with Squarespace they
make it easier than ever to launch your
passion project whether you're
showcasing your work or you want to sell
some products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you get stuck they have
a 24/7 award-winning customer support
that is there to help so head to
squarespace.com sasch grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain
[Music]
barbra Dunkleman is here we do fully
scripted podcast what I'm so excited
you're here - can't believe it's been
this long so I I guess I've just always
assumed every time I see you I'm just
like it feels like I'm catching up with
an old friend that I like we know each
other we found out we've done this
although I've been thinking about it we
haven't really done anything anything
with each other before right that's why
I was liking that one time in college
yeah
and that was unofficial but I every I
was so excited that you were in town and
able to do this because it just feels
like a long time coming so thank you so
much for making time thank you for
having me I've started this new thing as
of the previous podcasts that we just
recorded where I asked the guests a
question you probably hate answering but
like how do you describe what you do to
someone like what would you describe
your profession job scenario is yeah
it's difficult so it always depends on
what the situation I'm in it so if I go
to a convention usually I just describe
myself as a voice actress because that's
usually what I'm there for
mm-hmm but to the general public I say I
do online entertainment there you go
which could be taken in so many routes a
Online Entertainment that's not porn
yeah but my actual title within
roosterteeth is director of social media
and community marketing okay so it's
like a lot and how long cuz you're
originally from Canada mm-hmm and so I
ran you became a fan of roosterteeth and
then like that kind of developed into a
job and you talked them until they hired
me that's a great method but how long
ago is that that was in 2004 Wow
and I started watching roosterteeth like
a year old and like a year into their
series at that point and I discovered
them online I was just you know a 15
year old girl in Canada living with my
family and my brothers and they started
watching the show called red vs. blue
which at the time I'm like I just want
to listen the Spice Girls and chat
allow instant messenger and then I just
slowly started listening to the show and
started watching it and then got really
into the community at roosterteeth and
seven years later I think is when they
actually hired me but I'd never thought
it was going to be something that was
gonna happen to me that's not all nuts
oh wait what how was the hiring process
like what actually transpired there well
I knocked on Bernie Stewart notes so
after I graduated from college I would
write a lot of journals up on the
roosterteeth community side being like
I'm looking for work internships might
move to Toronto blah blah blah blah blah
and Bernie who you obviously are
familiar yeah founder of roosterteeth he
reached out to me knees like hey um we
really like you and we think that we
should try to find a place for you risk
your teeth don't know if it's possible
cuz you're in Canada and it's like whole
work visa thing or yeah but let's start
looking at options cool about I think it
was it was in June of 2011 that he
reached out and then by December I moved
down to Austin really yeah okay it
wouldn't happen these days with the work
visa oh god yeah this president says
don't get me started but that's all okay
how was Texas been compared to Canada
I'm sure you've answered this a thousand
times in your life like now as an adult
woman living in Texas how is that so
Texas in general is probably very
different
Austin is kind of not like the rest of
test sure Austin's like a liberal City
yeah
where's artistic is what I'm used to
yeah it's not too much different in
terms of just the way people are in the
way life is
mm-hmm I guess the biggest difference is
that people could just have guns
wherever they are right a little
off-putting yeah as a Canadian when I'm
used to seeing only cops with guns right
right right and it's really hot all the
time that's yeah all the time
oh that's super super fun I went to an
RTX convention I met Bernie through
Hannah and then he was like do you want
to come down to this convention no is
that guy yeah this look at a VidCon I
was like I love convention
and those like went down to our checks
and it was like completely out of my
realm of knowing anything or anyone or
what was going on yeah and Bernie was
like this little Pied Piper with all of
these like people following him
everywhere and Oh Bernie
I was so blown away by it and it's it is
such a community like it's massive
what I mean how has it changed over the
years I guess I'm like because you've
been one a very strong female force in
that community which is so cool to see
thank you
but also like it's a male-dominated
community in a lot of ways how have you
seen changes happen definitely yeah so I
again joined really early on 2004 where
they almost deleted my profile because
there was like no women on the websites
do they think it was like a hack Bernie
almost deleted my profile thinking it
was a fake
thank God he did it that would have been
life-changing if we had done that but
ever since I started I think I've seen a
really big influx of women both within
the community and the company yeah I
think I was the third or fourth woman
hired at roosterteeth and now we have I
think 450 employees and probably 40% are
women no I would say so it's insane to
see that and the community is well I
think has kind of followed suit yeah
especially since we started shows like
Ruby yeah and just had more women in
content yeah it's really helped you okay
so you've done you I get exhausted
looking up everything that you've done
like I was trying to do like a full deep
dive this morning and I was like there's
so much I'm sorry I was so pissed off at
such a successful career it was like she
wears 10,000 hats it's no items a beret
one and it's super cute and very now but
so you do would you right now you do
primarily voiceover I would say that's
probably what I'm primarily known for
okay yeah do people ever recognize your
voice without knowing your face that's
how that's happened to me only at
conventions really I was recently at New
York comic-con yeah and whenever we're
at comic-con we do a big Ruby push which
is our animated show and there was
people that had come up
booth and they came up to our table
where we were signing and some guy was
like um I'm looking for the the voice of
yang in Ruby and I was like oh that's me
and he goes oh cool you sound just like
her I can't believe I said and he's like
oh cool what's your name and I was like
oh that's weird because usually people
know me as Barbara first right
everything else kind of that I do on the
side that was different
yeah so you were just at comic-con how
many conventions do you think you've
gone to now in your stead at
roosterteeth probably a hundred that's
crazy
maybe more and conventions are such a
strange environment it's hard to explain
exactly like the controlled chaos that
happens there yeah do you have any
standout story of like either the most
Awkward fan encounter that you've ever
had and then follow up to that have you
ever had a very insane fangirl moment at
seeing someone else at a convention um I
mean I think every interaction is
awkward in in a way sure but only
because I'm such an awkward person yeah
girl welcome yes you're in a safe space
I think you could relate just people
coming up to me and being so excited and
overwhelmed to be meeting me and I'm
like I don't elicit these emotions in
people and especially when people get
emotional I'm like I'm really not that
cool but it's always so humbling to see
people get such a visceral reaction from
meeting you and yeah are so excited with
by something that you do or something
you've been in and I've had like way
more humbling and cool experiences than
anything though yeah and I definitely
get a little star-struck not in the same
sense I think that normal like people
normally do okay only because you see
the other side of it and like know what
it's like for someone to be a fan of you
and you're like I'm just a person so if
I'm a fan of someone else I'm like oh
they're just a person and I understand
that kind of relationship but I did see
the cast of the stranger things in the
green room one time at a convention all
the kids and they're all like 12 you're
working that company that plays video
games we play video games and I'm like I
mean those are the perfect people to
like awkwardly fangirl in front of
because they're going through their own
puberty right now apparently that kid
Caleb who's in stranger things just
turned 17 yeah I saw that they'll they
all love each other in Instagram I
follow some a lot of them on Instagram
so it may leave Bobby Brown is my style
icon oh she's just so confident in
herself she can we're literally like an
umbrella as a jacket and I'd be like
just perfect I think she did yeah okay
you also I was listening to this morning
always open yeah yeah which is on
windows gross stars are just like us
guys
so always open you guys are kind of on
hiatus now for a second yeah so we are
seasonal so she's know okay I think it's
six week breaks in between seasons and
this is a podcast when did this start
and how do you describe it to people so
always open started a September of 2016
okay oh my gosh it was like two years
ago yeah time flies and that started
because for a number of reasons but we
have a lot of different shows that
roosterteeth yeah that are all
male-dominated even the RT podcast tends
to be three guys and a girl or four guys
that's why I think you're such an
important force in that world that's I
was so excited about always open it
feels like it was probably spawned by
wanting to be represented in her yeah
couple different reasons yeah those are
those are big ones and I
someone who appears on the RT podcast
regularly something I've always been
very excited and passionate to talk
about is just sexuality and yeah bursa t
and relationships and everything kind of
like that but I didn't really have the
outlet for it
and the audience that has always liked
us talking about that kind of thing so
yeah because I think the disconnect is
that like quote nerd culture like gamer
culture doesn't connect with their
sexuality at all but there is a bridge
that can connect those two things I just
don't think that there's a spot that's
really connecting those so it seems like
that's a very like welcoming present
thank you yeah we try to make it that
way and I think also just on the
Internet in general I think it's become
so taboo to talk about sex
yeah and just kind of you guys really
talk about it yeah I was in my car this
morning listening being like oh my god
well I like Catholic roots or like my
Jewish parents are very proud but yeah I
think it's just something that people
should be more open about and just how
you feel about certain situations we've
had so many people write into the show
and say you guys talked about so-and-so
issue that I've been dealing with that I
didn't know was a regular thing oh
that's and so even just to like have one
person realized I'm not weird because
this is kind of the goal of the whole
thing have has there been like a
standout episode or topic that you guys
talked about or even like a regretful
one like this did not go over well my
parents wish I would take this down from
the internet yeah my parents are very
proud I actually do listen every week
and they actually quite like the show
that's great um we did a whole episode
about kinks one time okay where I feel
like I learned a little too much about
some of my friends because these are all
your close friends that you guys are
having extremely candid conversations
yeah yeah and you can't unhear certain
thing or unsee certain things no no you
have a video component some people try
to recreate some things that they tell
stories about Wow but one of my favorite
episodes
was it's actually now two episodes we've
done about mental health
we had Kati Morton on yeah who I'm sure
you guys Brenda the show a friend of
grace is a personal human being yeah
wonderful woman very smart very just
insightful yeah the whole topic and
having someone like that on who really
knows what she's talking about when none
of us do
right I think was a really eye-opening
experience that's very cool and I mean
now more than ever it's super important
to make those conversations casual and
candid and I don't know just
approachable yeah for people because I
think people are afraid to have real
conversations like that are there any
topics coming up that you guys are
excited about and like next season we
haven't quite figured them out yet okay
we yeah how does that what's the
brainstorming process for this kind of
podcast definitely not as put together
as we should be tears into it but it
feels like that's part of the charm
that's a good way of putting it part of
the charm uh-huh it's we have a creative
meeting every week where we basically
decide the cast okay if it's not someone
we're flying down if it's someone just
internal that we're gonna have on we're
like oh let's just ask them to be on the
show this week and then we run down the
topics based on who we're gonna have on
the show okay that's very cool okay
explain to me because you are a worldly
businesswoman what is your regular week
like like what is your workweek like I
know that there's no week that is
identical to a week before after but
what is on average like or just a day
like what does that look like for you
with a fully functioning digestive
system I don't know where I think I'm
just nervous to talk about my week guys
so much stress that your body's ejecting
it out one end not the other which is
good
it's okay these aren't my chairs they're
Jack's welcome I like to leave my set
wherever I go my space but no I again
like it doesn't exist a typical day or a
typical work week but if I had to
describe it I run the whole social media
and commune
rooster teeth's which it's only five
people under me so it's not too
difficult to manage
so five more people than I can manage
and also like I am not I'm a person
who's not cut out to be a manager
because I don't even have my own [ __ ]
together let alone telling other people
how to manage their [ __ ] yeah but
luckily they're extremely smart capable
people who know what they're doing so
it's really not a lot of hand-holding
okay it's required I'm just kind of like
I'm here if you need me yeah that's
great so usually I meet with them
throughout the week to make sure that
they know what they're doing they know
what our priorities are of what to
promote what to talk about and then have
some creative meetings whether it be for
always open or other shows that we're
gonna shoot that week we're getting back
into the writing process some of us at
risk youth who have never done it before
I'm actually starting to write now are
you which is really exciting but you
haven't done it before mm-hmm oh that's
so cool so I'm learning how do you write
a script that's exciting how's it going
it's good it's good and then oh yeah we
usually end up filming at least one or
two things per week whether it's the
podcasts or live-action content and
sometimes they'll go in the booth first
and voiceover for Ruby or camp camp or
any of our other animated shows that's
awesome and traveling usually is a
component yeah no you guys are you're
all mobile is it's so insane and you
guys have like full hangars in Austin
that the business runs out of now that
blows my mind how much it's like grown
in the last few years and there's no
bathrooms inside really know what you
piss outside what happens we do we have
buckets Texas it's quirky we should you
450 employees and buckets now they built
bathrooms outside for us because I guess
the hangars don't really have like that
okay that's bad I mean when you're a
creative bathrooms are an afterthought
guys so that's always they don't give us
any fluid at roosterteeth so I never
have to be everyone's just wildly
dehydrated all the time that's so funny
okay I also in a quick scan of your
Instagram you may
jvn I did tell me everything it was
brief okay but it was I would that is
when I've been starstruck yeah it was
Jonathan Van Ness for those of you that
don't know that is maybe the glue that
holds the queer I team together even
though they don't need it they're just
world change in God that we want to see
in the world yeah so I was at an event
for podcasters and I had just finished
doing like a stage presentation with
some other people very businessí it was
it was basically to advertisers sure and
I heard that he was also presenting
after me oh my goodness is like a full
day event so I was like he could have
been in the morning or writer that day
he happened me right after me and so
after I finished on stage I had like
bolted out of there because I hate being
in the way of people it's like I'm my
one anxiety thing where I'm like I never
want to be in the way of anything you
were fully speaking my language I
totally get it
and so um someone texted me who was
there and they're like hey JV and his
backstage I was like I just [ __ ]
course you can [ __ ] I just left cuz I
was across the street now having drinks
with some people and it's like how long
do you think he's gonna be there and
they're like he just got offstage he's
probably gonna be hanging around for
like a minute or two and so I like put
my drink down and I bolted across the
street and I went into the room and he
was facing away from me just a long hair
right there and it's like beautiful robe
cuz I like I know what it's like when
people come up to me when they're
nervous sure they're like just don't do
the things that I register and other
people I was like I just want to say
hello I know he'd probably doesn't want
to like meet people right now because he
just did this thing and now he's
backstage relaxing blah blah and so I
just like I tap him on the shoulder like
mmm excuse me uh hi I just wanted to say
like I I think you're awesome a really
big fan of your work and I was wondering
if I could just get a quick photo with
you and he goes sure any like turns and
like we take a photo and I'm like thank
you so much by the way you look awesome
yeah and he goes and he like smiles at
me and then turns back
that's the most perfect J that's exactly
how I imagined him to be I don't think I
would have that much courage to even do
it you did I think I would be too yeah I
couldn't I don't think I could even tap
him on the shoulder I don't know you
could see my like in the photo that I
took with him I was shaking and the
photos like not quite perfectly in focus
that was just a filter the filter did it
yeah I made it blurry on that just oh my
god okay um I just I don't know what I
would do we're gonna take a quick break
and we get back we have some ridiculous
questions for Barbara Dunkleman unknot
you're deeper after this Jack would you
like to turn your dream into a reality
with Squarespace you know I would grace
well few today's your day cuz they're
sponsoring this episode of not too deep
and they make it easier than ever to
launch your passion project that's true
whether you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work publish
content
sell products and more Squarespace is
the tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself Squarespace is powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
anything online and analytics help you
grow your site in real time and this is
something people might overlook but they
optimize everything for mobile right out
of the box and there's nothing to patch
your upgrade ever it's really important
because people will look at your site on
their phones yep and buying domains is
really simple and you'll get all the
help you need with their 24/7
award-winning customer support you need
it if you need it they're there for you
they empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms
JAC fairies that's right to turn great
ideas into something real in fact the
website for this very show is a
Squarespace site the inception of it all
yes and you guys can get ready by going
to squarespace.com slash grace for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that's where space.com slash
grace offer code grace support for
today's show comes from 3rd love using
millions
of real women's measurements third love
designs its bras with breast size and
shape in mind for an impeccable fit and
incredible feel just answer a few simple
questions from third love's fit finder
quiz to find your perfect fit third love
offers double the number of sizes that
most brands offer cups A through H bands
up to 48 and with lightweight memory
foam cups straps that won't slip and
tagless labels you want to wear the soft
but breathable bras and underwear every
day especially the new a cotton t-shirt
bras and underwear but thanks to the
100% fit guarantee returns and exchanges
are free and easy and you're talking to
a slop monster here that only once
comfort over fashion and so I'm always
living in a sports bra and they sent me
a couple of their bras and they're
fantastic I cannot say enough good
things about them
third love knows that there's a perfect
bra for everyone so right now they're
offering my listeners you beautiful
beautiful people 15% off your first
order go to third love comm slash grace
now to find your perfect fitting bra and
get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm slash grace for
15% off today thank you
god bless Squarespace you were just
telling me that that was your first
voiceover thing ever mm-hmm okay explain
to the people that are listening because
this is insane to me yeah so we were
just talking about Ruby which is the
first animated show that I've ever done
a voice for started back in 2013 and we
permeated our TX actually yeah and it
was created by someone named Monty Oum
brilliant amazing wonderful person and
he created these four main characters
for the show and he based one character
off of me and my personality and so when
he was creating them he approached me
about it and he said I would love for
you to play this character do you think
that's something you'd be interested in
I'm like absolutely yeah but I don't
know how to do voiceover so
hopefully I'm not [ __ ] at it but what
okay so what what's the learning curve
are you doing voiceover you had the one
learn to embrace your boys I did uh-huh
and we're also just talking about how
embarrassing and degrading it is to do
voiceover work at all it's very weird
it's you I find myself just stick you
lating a lot to no one because there's
no you know video quality to this but
it's good because it helps you yeah it
helps you but then you feel and there's
such a weird vulnerability about it I
don't know how to fully explain it it's
different yeah because when you're
actually on camera acting you are aware
that people are watching you but it's
because that's the performance right I
think you're so dialed in on this one
sensory organ your voice that you're
like am i speaking correctly yes saying
words properly how do I am I reading
things right proper emotion yes and I
think the biggest learning curve for me
was my idea of voice acting was always
you have to change your voice oh oh if
I'm if I'm doing a character's voice it
has to not be my own voice okay and so
when I first went in to read for the
character that I play which is yang I
did it like in a high-pitched kind of
tone hey guys what are you doing today
and they're like we face this on you
yeah can you just use your voice she's
also 17 and not 12 and so I just kind of
switch gears and just learn that voice
acting is just being able to act with
your voice whether or not that's a
different tone or a different type of
voice that you're doing it's just acting
that's super cool but also like a very
weird thing it seems like common
knowledge yeah and I get voice acting is
acting with your voice but that yeah I'm
the same way that literally whenever
I've put an audition on tape I'm like it
must be a character it must be something
that's not me you have a clothing and
accessories line with r-tx that is cute
as [ __ ] thank you I mean do people know
about this they should because I look
this up and I was like this is really
really cute do like girls should know
about this well yes we will send you
stuff grace oh my god
thank you thank you thank you for
reading between the lines I fully
appreciate it no thank you
I am very fortunate to be able to work
with such an amazing design team Irish
your teeth yeah they were they they
started off by doing Jeff Ramsay his
clothing line okay another guy rich
teeth who has a very particular style
mm-hmm and his whole thing was that he
didn't want to wear roosterteeth
merchandise because it didn't blend with
his fashion sense his personal brand
he doesn't quote shirts or things like
that yeah and so they're like what if we
make Russia t-shirts that are just like
stuff that you would wear uh-huh and
that's how that whole thing kicked off
and when that was a success they
approached me about it and they're like
why don't we make the barber Dunkleman
clothing line yeah and I was like cooee
call it something shorter but yeah I had
the opportunity to work with the design
team to come up with different lines and
different collections that we've been
doing and that is something that has
always been a dream of mine ever since
I've been a kid okay yeah okay cuz I was
looking at these designs no it's like
this resonates with me a hard core and
I'm curious to see like how hands-on you
were with it because I you know when
you're a young girl and you're not like
super girly but you want to be girly and
also have a tomboy kind of aspect to
your personality it's hard to find like
a space for you in like the fashion
world and accessories and I felt like
your line really kind of blended those
two things really well thank you yeah
kind of the intention of it because I am
kind of to this day still very much a
tomboy mm-hmm but I also like having
you're a girl and like being feminine at
you yeah and looking put together so for
each line or guest collection whatever
they're called yeah I came up with like
kind of a general theme for them and
then work with the designers on sending
inspiration and different cuts and
different designs that I like cool and
they kind of create mood boards and then
we take inspiration from different
things and then they kind of pitched
these different designs to me and we
make notes so I don't actually
physically design anything because I
don't have any graphic skills so that
it's a collaborative experience because
you're creating ultimately things that
you would want to wear if you didn't
design them and yeah
you guys want to get into the design
world just you know go with the idea of
wanting free clothing just find a
company that you like from a very young
age posting on their forums message
boards and then it will manifest itself
for yourself also in looking at your
social media you recently posted a photo
of yourself with brown hair and banks
what was going on there now I'm
rethinking everything and I posted in
the last yeah welcome to stalker calm /
- grace Helbig ya know as a woman that's
cut her own bangs twice in moments of
crises was this a crisis moment was this
just like an actual like I wanted bangs
I cut those bangs as well by myself in
my adult life they've been cut by myself
no that was I I get the urge to change
my hair probably once a month oh yeah
like I literally just added extensions
because I was like I'm bored I'm bored
and I'm impatient to let my hair grow by
itself yep yeah I've wanted to go
redhead probably a dozen times have you
never because it washes out pretty
quickly so I hear I hear like once you
go red it's like in your hair oh okay
until it's growing itself all the way
out gotcha
okay so it's a commitment it's like a
tattoo for your hair essentially there
you go like when you grow in your skin
is that the one that's like the ominous
one that you haven't actually like
that's the rainbow that you want to
chase yeah I think some day I'll do it
um but when I did dye my hair brown and
I don't want to make it sound like I'm
dissing all brunettes wait is your hair
naturally blonde mm-hmm Oh dirty blonde
god bless my hair's naturally brown so I
don't but I've also dyed it back to
brown in times of crisis fun um but I
did realize when I was a brunette for
that short period of time that I felt
very plain I'm not trying to say that
brunettes are plain but I also had the
same similar feeling just when you're
used to having very bright hair and
having like stand out in photos or
whatever it is and then all of a sudden
that's not there you're like oh if
very serious yeah it felt like I'm a
dumb human being by nature and I felt
like I wasn't allowed to be dumb when I
had brown hair like I felt like I had to
be more informed than I wanted to be did
it change your fashion sense too
because oh they did to me yeah I wore
sweatpants a lot but it really changed
that but it made me think that
sweatpants wear fashion heels with them
yeah exactly
just put some ankle booties with them
and yeah now you're a part of the
regular world have you ever gone like
super-short only once in high school
and it was like chin length oh yeah I
don't know if I'd ever go any shorter
than that I have a route like because
I've been 5 foot 9 ever since I was 12
and really in a computer it's an awkward
story but so I have like a bad hunch
same and I've had basically my entire
life and so I feel like if I cut my hair
it'll just show the hunch more I am a
thousand percent with you yes I'm 5 foot
9 also but I it happened later in high
school and as a person that's dated
shorter guys I think I've just tried to
get them into yourself like this yeah
just like to help them feel comfortable
and so yeah I still struggle with like
posture in general me too and that's my
hair exists and her extensions covers
everything ok what was the last big
house gathering you hosted well I have a
one-bedroom apartment so could only
really fit four people in there max okay
so I had some friends over for a game
night a couple weeks ago how'd that go
it was good yeah we we played this game
called concept what's that
it's either German or like some other
place and you hear okay
it's basically like a game of charades
but with pictures on a board okay so
like you'll get a card that has a I
think six different words and it ranges
from very easy to very difficult okay so
like an easy one will be
princess and so you could put like a
tile on girl and a tile unlike fictional
and like all these different things to
kind of indicate what you're trying to
say and then people guess and you could
kind of like say yes to certain things
but you can't say no but you're not
acting out anything right you're just
placing tiles on a board that has
pictures on it oh it's it's very control
it's so much fun it's fun I've never
heard of it before I should try it out
concept what a great concept is there
and Squarespace is there a if you could
create a game have you ever thought
about doing that oh I I don't think I'm
smart enough to be honest here games
involves so much thought and process and
just thinking about all the different
outcomes of different things that I
don't think I could wrap my head around
it yeah I think I would if I had to come
up with like the start of a game like
the initial idea and then it would never
finish so no one would ever finish the
game and they'd be extremely frustrated
by me or extremely satisfied because
it's a game that never finished ever
ends yeah what's your other than concept
what are your top games that you're into
right now I really like code names I
don't know that either
I don't know anything I've lived in LA
yeah I just started words with friends a
couple weeks ago I'm so behind on games
I'm terrible at this great game called
candy crush you should check it code
names code names code names
um awesome game you play it in teams and
you have a table that has all these
different words on it so it could be
like spoon hairbrush Tokyo like etc etc
okay and two people will sit on one end
and they're the clue givers one from one
team one from the other and there's a
board that shows all the tiles that are
yours and all the tiles that are the
other teams and you have to make your
team guess what words you have and try
to get all of them figured out before
the other team well and so like let's
say I have Tokyo New York and LA I could
be like alright your code word is places
and three words so yeah
to be like okay let's look at the board
and see what matches the word places
whoa and yet to get really creative with
it sometimes because if you have Tokyo
New York and LA but there's also Alaska
on the braid right right I guess not one
of your tiles but you can only give one
word descriptions your clues oh now I
want to play right now can we stop the
fight that's on super fun okay what's
another like game that you wreck right
now I've always been a really big fan of
cranium oh yeah you ever played that
yeah that's a classic that's fun for the
whole family if you want to like induce
stress within everyone yeah seeing my
two brothers play on the same team at
cranium is probably the funniest thing
I've ever seen really because my younger
brother it gets so frustrated with my
older brother brother and my older
brother can't guess any clues ever and
so one time they were doing the
pictionary game and they had the clue
men without hats
okay and so my little brother was drying
it and my older brother was like men not
wearing hats men that don't have hats on
their heads and I just kept going in
every direction that wasn't me I show
clear which is insanely frustrating and
will drive a family apart from each
other don't talk anymore games are the
bonder and the completely driving force
between families god bless him okay
who was your favorite recurring guest on
always open oh man I think one of my
favorite people to have on there is
Miles Luna yeah he's a friend of ours at
the company he was one of the writers on
Ruby and when our head writer and
animation he is one of the best
storytellers I've ever met really and
having him on that show and him going
into vivid details about certain things
it's just it's just life changing it's
yeah I'm sure he paints many pictures he
told this story about his first [ __ ]
which I will never forget received or
given received receives you say it was a
girl in high school who handcuffed him
to the bed and then played heavy metal
music while she went
it's not technically what a [ __ ]
should be and she got a beat she had a
rhythm to go to I can see how can we get
him on this okay who is the biggest
gossip in your family you said you have
an older brother and younger brother
you're the middle child mm-hmm okay
same yeah I'm not the same person I
think so we get confused with each other
on twitter via people these names look
in the mirror and I go oh I thought I
was great for a sec to save it I thought
I was Ruby the whole time so great uh do
like how much older is your older
brother and how much younger is your
younger my older brother is two and a
half years older okay and then my
younger brother is four and a half
almost five years younger okay
are either one of them like big gossips
no no not at all I would say my mom is
probably the biggest gossip in the
family she loves knowing everybody's
secrets but she also you said that your
parents are super supportive of you
working at r-tx is she like really kind
of involved in like your work space
there my parents are a little too
involved in roosterteeth freely um and
I've told them this before so it's not
gonna come as a shock to them when they
listen to this uh-huh they listen to the
podcast every week if they watch always
open every week they follow me on
Twitter they follow everyone every
should teeth on Twitter and every social
media
I got snapchat so they got snapchat oh
your parents have snapchat just to
follow me so now I don't use snapchat
anymore and like it's it's nice to have
parents who are so supportive and they
care about what you do but it's also
like I know that whatever I say my
parents are gonna hear it yeah do they
respond to fans ever have you ever had
to it like call them up and be like you
gotta chill out first I can't please
absolutely um my mom used to do this
thing which she might get upset about me
talking about in the show but for a big
fan of mom it's okay yeah I love you
wonderful and I love her but she used to
respond to fans who tweeted at me she
would respond to them and hashtag her
tweets Barb's
[Laughter]
her Twitter account isn't Barb's mom no
but I think she wishes it could be I'm
like can you guys talk to someone at
Twitter and get her on there as Barb's
mom so she can forego the hashtag I
think she tweeted you after you sent out
a tweet about today this show oh god
well I'm gonna find it actually that's
the perfect segue we're gonna take one
more break and then get into some
internet questions perhaps from hashtag
Barb's mom this episode is brought to
you by the burst sonic toothbrush it is
the best oral care you'll ever buy the
Bur sonic toothbrush has a built-in
two-minute timer and is designed to make
teeth whiter and brighter in just days
burst is best known for its charcoal
infuse super soft bristles the truck
removes surface stains and is
antimicrobial I'm learning how to
pronounce that word it's very important
which helps keep the bristles hygienic
for the lifetime of the brush head it's
proven to remove plaque and stains
without damaging enamel or your guns and
burst has the most powerful motor on the
market and the longest battery life with
up to four weeks use on just one hours
charge and to be very fair because
that's all we are here I'm not too deep
they sent me this toothbrush I loved it
very much I am in a hotel room recording
this at copy right now with the
toothbrush in my bathroom in this hotel
room and it's yeah it's my go to so go
to burst oral CARICOM to get your burst
sonic toothbrush today and with the
birth subscription program you'll get a
new replacement head every three months
for just six dollars each if you use my
code grace grac ii a check
Cal you also get 10% off your order
that's burst oral care comm with code
grace for 10% off don't miss out on this
special offer it's a great gift idea to
just put it out there to all your gross
mouth friends go to burst oral CARICOM
and don't forget the code grace we're
back with barbara document angleman
Dan Goleman Dan Goleman the correct
Canadian pronunciation okay we're gonna
get into some Twitter questions one of
which submitted by your mother but
before we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions I ask every guest that is on
the podcast and the first is who alive
or dead would you most want to throw
cold spaghetti at
gosh I know you're Canadian and nice and
this is a hard question I mean is it a
political statement if I say Donald
Trump not at all and how many of your
previous guests have said
Danny's probably the most popular in
Smitty but it's not even a political
statement I feel like it's just a
personal statement of just like human to
human hair okay you should I don't like
what you're doing I would that should be
produced okay the other question or ask
is to tell us your worst pants shooting
story or close call we can only use
three words or three small phrases -
college jogging front lawn Wow
yeah oh I'm so sorry I'm sorry for them
mine would be apartment movie woopsie
included another word or phrase would be
thought it was a fart that's been a
common theme yeah people trusted the
fart and that's like kind of the biggest
lesson in adulthood I've learned from
doing this podcast the last five years
never trust a fart yeah no don't I've
also shat myself probably more than the
average person and I'm not
to admit that that makes you so much
more relatable I carry extra clothes in
my car just because I don't trust my
systems in my body at all me too
I think that's how you become mature
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions the first is from Marion
Letterman she says when will this be
available asking for a friend or mom I
believe this is your mother
he got right in there I don't want to
search all her tweets and find out every
time she mentions the word mom I mean
unfortunately she did not have tagged it
Barb's mom but right in there and it's
very very sweet and Marion this should
be available on December 10th but we
will keep you abreast of this beforehand
don't worry okay someone to know as an
Ontario to Ontarian is that the right
way to say that I think so okay how do
you keep it real eh oh oh don't you know
because more Minnesotan than Canadian uh
how do I keep it real I just I don't
know how to not be just me yeah and I
feel like a lot of people when I meet
them in person they're like oh you're
the same as you are in your podcasts or
whatever Emily yeah I don't know really
how to put on a character that's like a
lot of people do I think on YouTube or
just an entertainment in general yeah I
think that's great it's less exhausting
like put a mask on then take one off the
only mask I put on are these fake
eyelashes yeah accidentally brought the
big boys this trip I didn't bring like
my subtle ones I love them they look
great I wish I knew how to apply them
properly I would be rocking the constant
took me 20 years I finally learned I
started when I was nine supposed to know
best and worst drinks from always open
Oh cuz what's that you guys are drinking
every episode yeah okay I'm a real
bartender on the show you do okay and so
it's like up to their discretion what
they're making every episode so we do
we do that yeah we also you know it's
just like folding and unfolding ladders
doors the maintenance guy outside sorry
guys you guys hear anything in the
background it's just someone falling off
a ladder constantly yeah it's very
dangerous yeah if only you could see no
we have shots that we do at the
beginning of every episode is it Lemon
Drop every time not every time okay
it's been I think two or three times
because we don't keep track of the shots
we do so like once like 20 or 30
episodes go by we're like Oh someone
submitted a lemon drop this sounds good
sometimes some people have submitted
some very questionable so it's always
user submitted okay we don't always do
them okay we don't always follow them to
a tee sometimes the bartender will be
like that'll be disgusting don't yeah
I'll do this instead of that
have there been any standouts there was
one that tasted like cheesecake and I
don't remember the name of it yeah I was
like a raspberry liqueur plus something
else and it just like all came together
and tasted like cheesecake that sounds I
mean dangerous is what it was amazingly
dangerous can we afford a bartender on
this podcast please in the future
literal cheesecake in a blender with
vodka and I'll drink it it's hot right
I'm a bartender supposed to know how
would you describe your perfect Sunday
my perfect Sunday I assume this means
cuz you don't have like a set schedule
some of the assuming Sunday means a day
you don't have to work yes
yeah we're travel yeah my perfect Sunday
would be waking up at like 10 11 o'clock
I say Barry we've been to like two when
I was like in college in high school hmm
can't do that anymore
my body's just like sleeping in going to
brunch cuz I'm a [ __ ] for brunches
everyone in Austin is yes Austin I was a
pescetarian for a long time and Austin
had a Bloody Mary when I was down there
for a South by Southwest years ago with
candied bacon in it and it turned me
completely and Austin brunch is nothing
too
be messed with it's not it's no joke
yeah definitely good brunch and that I
probably want to go to a movie the Alamo
Drafthouse is like my favorite place Oh
fun and then go shopping it's like one
way that I relax and then watch some
Netflix have some pizza go to sleep
[Laughter]
subscribe a perfect bang okay if the
supposed to know if there was one thing
if there's one negative thing you could
eradicate from the world what would it
be
I'm assuming that's a very intelligent
way of saying what's your pet peeve I
mean that's a grandiose scale of one
thing you could eliminate from the world
my pet peeves is just bad drivers I know
it's kind of like a generic thing but oh
yeah people who don't use their signal
yeah this is how I know that I'm like a
full-fledged adult is that I get furious
when someone doesn't use their turn
signal furious I like cars our advanced
technology and they have these buttons
in there to help everyone else because
we can't scream outside that we're gonna
turn right or left
someone not using their turn signal is
how I got into my one and only car
accident really it was barely anything I
was driving behind someone and they were
going pretty fast I was going pretty
fast but I was still like a normal
distance away from them then all of a
sudden they slam on their brakes to turn
and I'm like oh so I slam on my brakes
and they end up hitting them in the back
I hate that and you're like what the
[ __ ] you do I'm like you you can't
signal you didn't give me a literal
signal yeah like the only way a car
communicates with another car is through
these lights that we have that's
incredible amazing that they put these
functions in you don't use them my other
pet peeve and I don't know if it would
be a pet peeve or something that I would
like to add more to the world
uh-huh I wish people had more empathy I
wish that was a thing that existed in
our society yeah a more broad way okay
so we are the exact same person I am
with you 10,000 percent yeah I mean now
more than ever - it's like patient
understanding and
I think honestly that's the reason why
there's such a divide in so many things
that are discussed especially online is
that people just don't understand yeah
other people in other ways of life and
and you know I think that's a big reason
why we have the current administration
that we do is because those small towns
don't get exposed to so many different
ways of life yeah
and they don't understand what it's like
to be gay or black or anything like that
or they've never met anybody yeah who's
in that position and so they can't
empathize with those people on certain
issues it must be kind of insane to be
part of a platform that is like super
global that provides kind of like
storytelling in perspective from
different you know lives to people they
don't have any access to that outside of
like their small towns yeah it also
still see like closed mindedness and
still see like lack of empathy lack of
understanding or lack of like wanting to
understand yeah that's the worst when
people just are so dead-set he's
stubborn and don't even want to hear a
different perspective but I've been very
lucky to be able to do always open and
to reach the audience that we have
there's actually a few times especially
at r-tx where people have come up to me
and said that they grew up in a very
kind of closed-minded religious
household they started watching the show
and they're like I never realized the
hardships that this group of people went
through yeah or that this was like and
so like it really opened my eyes to this
and I was like could you share this with
10 of your friends yeah yeah literally
pass it on yeah that must be so
fulfilling then to be able to do
something that one you probably wanted
to hear and watch when you were younger
and be able to provide that now for
someone else I'm sure you get to like
like I get to figure out more about
myself doing this show that you must be
able to figure out more about like your
views your life and perspective by doing
that and kind of figure out how much you
don't know yeah and I think more people
need to be okay with that sorry I'm like
having a therapy session right now this
is the one-on-one now
close down your laptops no absolutely
it's like being okay not knowing it's
easier said than done but like feeling
okay being curious and asking what you
think are dumb questions yeah I think is
really important and just being
open-minded and and respectful I'm so
excited for more always open can I come
on an episode yes please I would love to
actually have a little gift for you
what okay sorry this is it's in my
backpack wait you're not allowed to give
me a gift until I give you again -
except vice versa this is okay so this
is a yellow mouth right you know okay uh
this is fantastic thank you so much this
is so cool I would love to have you on
the show I've honestly like I'll be
completely real with you and like I've
been so intimidated to invite you on the
show because like you are like one of my
biggest like role models and people who
I look up to in the industry and I'm
like she never want to come on the show
oh my I just - she's too good for I
don't know if I should even ask her if
she would be offended but no okay we
literally are the same person because
I'm so intimidated by like the amount of
success and everything that you're doing
and all of the ways that you are like
being yourself in an industry that is
very hard to get into as just a human
being let alone a female let alone like
a female with like I don't know
confidence and like jurisdiction it's
not like no I so I obviously yes I would
love to absolutely give myself an open
invitation on my own episode just see
which episode comes out first because
we're very late to the game but now I
mean in the you know the spirit of
gift-giving I feel like we have to give
you the gift for being on this podcast
with us which isn't a very it's not
wrapped in plastic
everyone's touched it it's it's well
why not you can actually yeah you can is
like you don't have to
I have very I'd blow bars for
cleanliness so you have to get on the
plane later so I might not but you can
technically is this you guys put your
own fortune in this yeah we touch it
it's a long ass fortune yep
sorry you want to know the murky design
first dude is like really really really
really really cute did I get really
really really really really really cute
and we would really really really really
say no to any free stuff you might have
lying around but like only if you wanna
idk now we feel embarrassed for for
bringing it up yeah exactly my internal
thoughts translated anything and
everything Oh Barbara I'm your size and
we'll we'll hit it up perfect I mean I
already got my my gift was like you
being on this podcast this was super fun
and I feel like I have so much more to
ask you so we should do more episodes in
the future whenever you're in town
anytime but for people that do not know
where can they find everything that
you're up to everything that you're
doing huh calm the responsive I you
could find me pretty much on every
social media platform except snapchat be
dope lemon which is BD u n ke l ma n and
then I'm also in roosterteeth content
that's at roosterteeth calm awesome are
you are you doing any conventions coming
up are you doing any public appearances
yeah so we have one as actually might
come out around the time that we're at
this convention we're gonna be in
Louisville Kentucky at the end of
November early December
and then we're like the me and the Ruby
girls where we go to conventions like
once a month in different cities so just
some keep keep an eye on our Twitter's
yeah check into their social media and
just make sure that you're caught up on
all things Barbara dongle man thank you
so much it's a super fun thank you of
course I'll see you guys next time when
I'm on 2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep third
love is passionate about the perfect fit
and they believe it's time for your bra
to fit you not the other way around
their collections are designed by women
for women so you'll love the way you
feel under each and every look and now
they offer over 70 sizes and more than a
dozen styles so you'll find the perfect
bra for every moment and every outfit
get 15% off your first purchase by going
to third love comm slash grace today not
too deep as a production of grace helbig
incorporated a producer and directed by
Jack ferry producer and editor
Melissa demons writing by Diane Kang
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]